here in Copenhagen is midway through the
second week of talks it's freezing
outside actually it's snowing but inside
the bella center temperatures are
soaring talks are completely deadlocked
over deep divides between rich and poor
nations today I met with one
climatologist who's seen it all before
over the past three decades stephen
schneider has worked at the interface of
climate science and policy writing in
his new book science as a contact sport
Schneider says that a time's the journey
has been turbulent I started by asking
Schneider whether he thought Stark
warnings from climatologists we're
finally getting through to policymakers
here in Copenhagen science doesn't tell
you how to do anything science is risk
risk is what can happen multiplied times
the probability will happen risk
management is what kind of risks do you
want to take with a planetary life
support system I happen to be a risk
averse person and I think that we should
be investing tremendously to reduce it
but that's a personal value judgment
other people say that's going to hurt
the market share of the coal industry
which employs a million people and
that's too serious a side effect we'll
just tolerate climate so you're really
running a whole series of value
judgments about how much insurance you
want to buy for the planetary life
support system
what's worse now is the ugliness of the
attacks back then they would say oh
you're wrong headed you're ignoring the
Sun now they send professor flip-flop
cooling then now warming you're just a
liar and then they use words that I
can't put on your blog site they tell me
I'm unamerican because I work with the
UN which wants to kill American
independence and what I thought in
science as a contact sport was history
is worse now than it was before
sometimes they get so annoyed I call it
the deniers Battle of the Bulge just
like in 44 when the Germans knew they
were going to lose the war well let's
take down as many as we can with us and
that's sort of what's going on now it's
just really outrageous
let me start with EU target of two
degrees which is quite sensible but it
is not a target of dangerous because at
one point eight there will be plenty of
dangerous things at to point to the
world doesn't turn into a climatic
pumpkin where everything comes to an end
it's not a runaway greenhouse effect
what it is is it's a judgment about
where to put a line in the sand on
enough is enough it's based on science
including my chapter an IPCC where we
show not that there's a hard threshold
at two degrees above but that there's an
accumulation of the number of systems
hurt and the depth to which the harm
occurs around two it's not a hard to its
spread out over you know maybe one two
three and after three you really start
getting nasty outcomes why else do you
say to because the political realists
they know the inertia in the system they
know it takes decades to replace lots of
coal with alternatives they know it's
going to take even longer than that to
get the developing world to agree to
leapfrog over the Industrial Revolution
so they named the lowest number that we
have a plausible shot at
I don't see any way that we stay under
one and a half and I'm with tuvalu but
it's just unlikely to happen
scientifically I think there's a very
high probability that we will overshoot
that two degree target by a fair amount
and then comes screaming off the back
end probably after we have catastrophic
events 20 30 years from now then people
say oh my god what have we done by that
time we've invented cheap enough
technology to get it done I hope that
that scenario doesn't happen but at the
moment I would not you know bet a lot
against it but the science itself can't
tell you what to do
I'm disappointed in the u.s. position
but that's because I'm angry about the
Congressional position and relatively
happy about the administration position
which collectively leads to a very weak
short-term set of goals but I think
there's too much focus among the
developing countries and the small
island states on what we do in terms of
the percentages of cuts to 2020 fact
when I get mad I said come on guys get
off the numerology how much we cut to 20
20 is not really that important what's
important is that by 2030 40 and 50
we're down to well below eighty percent
of these emissions the numerology I want
us to be binding ly committed to is how
many tens of billions are going to spend
every year waiting to spend it on and
how you're going to help the developing
world leapfrog over the Industrial
Revolution and how you're going to help
the poorest of the poor with adaptation
to problems they didn't create that's
the numbers I care about I suspect the
Copenhagen will have you or a week or no
target it will have some aspirational
goal which is good and that aspirational
goal will probably be expressed beyond
2020 like 20-30 because it does take
more than a decade to get rid of
existing infrastructure but what if it
does right what it will do is it will
set up finance mechanisms for both
adaptation and for technology transfer
if Copenhagen starts to set those up
even though they won't be final I will
not consider it a failure remember we
cannot let the perfect be the enemy of
the mediocre you know the cliche is the
good we're not going to get near good
but mediocre is better than going at
high speed in the wrong direction like
we did in the bush administration that
was done for climatologist stephen
schneider just two days remain now
before more than 100 world leaders will
descend on copenhagen hoping to sign a
historic deal on climate change inside
the bella center opinion remains divided
over whether their arrival will give the
negotiation
a much needed push whether these talks
will actually result in a climate change
deal even a mediocre one remains
anyone's gasps this is Oliver fronting
for nature and Copenhagen we'll be
posting videos and blogs for the rest of
the week so check in with us later
you